j'ai dit que je souhaitais que nous
puissions prendre cette décision le plus
collectivement possible et que je ne
souhaitais pas être enfin je sais que
mon nom est cité parce que par fonction
je suis aujourd'hui prise en groupe et
donc dans avec une direction collégiale
à 28 forcément moi je fais figure de
chef nous a des façons mais je ne
souhaite pas accaparer tous les pouvoirs
moi je ne suis pas jupiter et je ne
souhaite pas que nous ayons comme signal
comme modèle le fait d'avoir des gens
qui finalement pas d'une case à l'autre
est toujours en pensant d'abord à leur
propre destin moi je voudrais que nous
pensions collectivement et qui après
avoir dit beaucoup jeu on puisse dire à
nouveau nous et donc je préférerais
qu'on ait un autre premier ou première
secrétaire avec lequel ou laquelle je
travaillerai en équipe parce que si on
veut marquer des buts il faut une équipe
il faut des gens qui soient alors ça
veut dire qu'il ya des ailiers il
faudrait mieux de thé record que
savez-vous ensemble ils répètent pas
vous ne serez pas le prochain secrétaire
mais ça fait ça veut dire que l'addition
sera collective que je ne veux pas me
dérober par avance si il se trouvait que
j'étais une solution pour beaucoup mais
que ce n'est pas mon choix mon choix
c'est d'être président de groupe et de
travailler avec un ou plutôt une image
plutôt vu de votre joie aujourd'hui à ce
qu'il ya aujourd'hui beaucoup de femmes
de qualité au parti socialiste et au
procès ceci je pense à najat vallaud
belkacem je pense delphine batho valérie
rabault anatolienne doré serait donc une
bonne candidate pour le pense que tout
serait des bonnes candidates je pense
qu'elles ont le talent le caractère
l'énergie l'intelligence le talent une
femme attend qu'ils sont plutôt une
femme parce que ça serait une façon
aussi de dire que l ont aussi leur place
dans la vie politique et que
ne sommes pas parfaits mais taper du
poing sur la table la semaine dernière
contre françois hollande parce que vous
avez peut-être eu le sentiment qu'il
manoeuvrait un peu en coulisses en vue
de ce congrès il ya on voit de sarko
isation le fait comme ça de recevoir
tout le monde décide d'être le parrain
de la gauche je crois pas que ces envois
de sarko isation mais une tentation chez
toutes celles et ceux qui ont un jour
diriger leur parti et soutien de
françois hollande qui ont même conduit à
la victoire de ne pas perdre
complètement la main et moi je crois que
le meilleur service que françois
hollande puisse rendre aujourd'hui au
socialiste c'est de ne pas chercher à
prendre la main mais le laisser cette
génération qui vient là prendre
complètement et de l'accompagner plutôt
que de la diriger